you write all these movies on a on a on
paper and Pen right yeah boy and and
when you do that you never say to
yourself hey you know what [ __ ] it I'm
gonna go to the computer it's so much
easier
well I eventually go to the computer
after I've finished my first draft how
does it work in other words you get an
idea hatefully you were like kind of you
love Bonanza you love the old western oh
you've heard that stuff yeah yeah that's
true you love all that yeah yeah right
and then you're sitting there and you're
taking a shower you know or you're
sitting by the pool you say you write
your movies sometimes you just kind of
chilling out there always is the
inciting idea that gets me to actually
sit down at the desk and and take a
bunch of blank pieces of paper and start
writing right from scratch well here's
the idea was the fact that in the last
few years I have a real big TV
collection I've been taping Random
episodes off of Television that I like
what are you watching uh well just I'm
in particularly older shows right and so
the thing about it is when I'd watch a
Virginian or a bonanza or a High
Chaparral or whatever the deal is I in
particularly focus on the episodes that
have like really cool guest stars yes on
those episodes those are good you know
like a Robert Culp or a James Park uh
Michael Parks or uh James Coburn or Vic
Morrow people show up for an episode
yeah exactly yeah now and I noticed
pretty quickly that if Robert cope was
uh uh the guest star on a Virginian the
story wasn't about trampus Doug McClure
it was about Robert Colt right it was
his story yes and in almost all these
cases they're always a stranger that
comes into the situation
uh you don't quite serious yeah
mysterious you don't quite know what's
going on right at some point
uh uh a dark complicated past yeah is
revealed about the character right and
you don't know if it's true or not it's
a thing that kind of hangs over the
character's head and you actually almost
have to watch the entire episode to see
if the guy is a good guy or a bad guy
you know what you're like a goddamn
Professor you're absolutely right every
episode that I ever liked at every
episode I ever liked of any of these
things hold on every episode I ever
liked it's always some [ __ ] [ __ ]
even Andy and Mayberry some douchebag
some guy will come into town yeah yeah
and no one knows what and I remember
even on Andy and Mayberry yeah Barney
was freaking out over some guy because
he thought he was up to some weird [ __ ]
he's never the bank robber yeah yeah you
know what I mean it was like there's
always something weird yeah so you said
to yourself but yeah I'm gonna make a
movie where some [ __ ] comes in from
out of town well no the idea though was
the was the idea okay let me do
a movie that stars nothing but those
guys there's no Little Joe oh there's no
Trappist Doug McClure there's no James
Arness it's a room full of guys that
nobody knows mysterious dudes all
mysterious all nefarious you can't quite
trust anything they say per se you have
to watch the whole thing to find out
what's going on but there's no hero
there's no moral Center I love that
foreign